MARTHA McSALARY, DR. MARC
SIEGEL AND JASON CHAFFETZ.
SOMETIMES THERE ARE TYPES IN
LIFE THAT MAKE US REALIZE HOW
LUCKY WE ARE AND HOW SPECIAL OUR
LIVES ARE.
IT’S DIFFICULT AS IT MAY BE TO
SEE THIS NOW, THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TIMES.
AMERICA IS DIFFERENT TODAY THAN
IT WAS EVEN LAST WEEK.
WE ARE FACING AN INCREDIBLY
CONTAGIOUS AND DANGEROUS VIRUS
MOVING ACROSS THE WORLD FROM ONE
HOT SPOT TO ANOTHER.
AS A RESULT AMERICA IS CHANGE
HOW WE OPERATE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT AT A LOWER
SPACE.
IT’S SOMETHING WE ARE NOT USED
TO.
WE ARE AMERICANS.
WE MOVE FAST.
WE COME AND GO AS WE PLEASE.
AND WINIER ACT WITH WHOMEVER OR
WHEREVER WE WANT.
BUT NOT ANYMORE IT’S A
FREAKISHLY ABNORMAL SHUTDOWN.
I CHANGED MY DAILY ROUTINE JUST
LIKE MANY OF YOU HAVE.
AND I’M MISERABLE LIKE MANY OF
YOU PROBABLY ARE.
MARCH MADNESS TO THE MASTERS,
FROM KINDERGARTEN TO COLLEGE,
STUDENTS BEING SENT HOME.
EVENTS CANCELED.
AIRPORTS LIMITED, BROADWAY GONE
DARK.
ALL THE NEWS IS DISPER IS DIS-SP
OUR DETERMINATION AND
PERSEVERANCE ARE HALLMARKS OF
WHO WE ARE AND FROM WHENCE WE
CAME.
WE BATTEN DOWN THE HATCHES
UNTIL LIFE RUSHES TO NORMAL.
WE LEARN AND PRACTICE SACRIFICE.
LIKE OUR FAMILIES HAVE FOR
GENERATIONS.
WE’LL NOW PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
ULTIMATELY, NO LAND CROWDS, NO
UPPING, NO HUGGING.
SPENDING MORE TYPE ALONE AS
EXPERTS HOPE TO PLANT THE
CURVE -- TO FLATTEN THE CURVE OF
THE VIRUS.
THIS WILL TAKE SELF-DISCIPLINE
AND CONTROL.
WE HAVE TO BUCKLE UP AND TOUGH
IT OUT.
AND LOOKING BACK AT THIS, IT
WILL BE JUST A BLIP ON THE
SCREEN OF LIFE.
HOW TO DO THAT?
STAY BUSY AND KEEP CALM.
I WATCHED PEOPLE PANICKING IN A
SUPERMARKET.
PANIC IS A WASTE OF ENERGY AND
IS EXHAUSTING.
THIS IS THE TIME FOR KINDNESS
AND GRACE AND GENEROSITY.
ARE THERE SENIOR CITIZENS THAT
YOU KNOW WHO CAN’T GET TO A
GROCERY STORE OR CO-WHO COULD
USE A HOPE COOKED MEAL YOU ARE
PROBABLY MAKING MORE OF THESE
DAYS?
AND YOU MUST BE INFORMED ABOUT
THIS VIRUS.
YOU CANNOT BE COPY SENT.
WHILE CHILDREN DON’T SEEM TO BE
AFFECTED, KIDS CAN BE CARRIERS
WHO WITH JUST A SIMPLE HUG OR
KISS TO GRANDMA CAN PASS
SOMETHING THAT MAY BE HARMLESS
TO THE CHILD BUT LETHAL TO THE
OLDER PERSON.
PITCH IN.
IT WILL MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER.
WE SAW IT JUST YESTERDAY AS THE
GIANTS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
STEPPED UP WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WALMART, WALGREENS, CVS AND MORE
WHO STEPPED UP TO HELP US GET
THROUGH THIS, EBB THOUGH THEY
KNOW THEY WILL TAKE A FINANCIAL
HIT.
LIKE THEM WE NEED TO BE STRONG
ENOUGH TO KNOW WHAT WE FACE AND
STRONG ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE NEED TO DO ABOUT IT.
AS THE EXPERTS CONTINUE THEIR
MISSION.
I WONDER HOW MUCH OF US WILL USE
THIS TIME TO EXAMINE OUR LIVES
AND ASSESS WHAT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT.
ONE MINUTE WE ARE ENJOYING THE
BOUNTIES OF LIFE, THEN LIKE A
THUNDERBOLT, OUR LIVES ARE
SUDDENLY CHANGED.
MAYBE JUST MAYBE WE ARE BLESSED
WITH A TIME FOR INTROSPECTION.
MY INTROSPECTION ISN’T FORMED BY
MY BELIEF IN GOD.
TAKE THIS TIME TO DECIDE WHAT’S